[Musique]
oh
moi
[Musique]
nous période toujours rêvé de
soitec risque alcool moi j'avais été les
échos la femme est en cours d'année nous
allons super il y avait très peu de
places disponibles est
je me suis un peu laissé aller et alors
c'est à une vue de l'arrivée sur la
bouée en examen que je me suis dirigé
vers la mécanique parce que finalement
ball moi j'en avais toujours un peu
rêver alors j'ai suivi les stages de
mécanique formation accélérée puis après
je suis rentré chez de patronne ils
savent bien marcher puis mais ça fait
deux ans que je suis ne pas tout à fait
des zincs jusqu'à vendredi
mais je suis en train de faire une
expertise et pour pouvoir chiffrer
pouvoir faire un devis de réparation qui
me donnera si le prix de la voiture
correspond aux prises en réparations
parce que comme la carrosserie est assez
vite assez malsaine
il vaudrait mieux peut-être la mettra à
la fira yeux que
que de la réparer parce que sinon ça ne
m'aurait pas le coup alors si les
clients qui vous est demandé de regarder
qui m'a demandé de vérifier si ça valait
bien le coup de la réparer ou pas
à les
contacter brigitte
et griller
le
comme d'habitude on a déblayé paiement à
la rentrée
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites je suis en
train de me régler la la richesse des
retards l'orateur
tourne pas très rond
et vous savez réparer tous les moteurs
avec les appareils qu'on n'a pas y'a pas
de problème on arrive à régler tous les
montants
de patience pour avoir la patience et en
quoi
bon alors là je vais finir mon réglage à
quoi sert le stroboscope pour votre
fille était là il sert à régler
exactement
l'étincelle au coin
on peut dresser wayne rooney a su aller
moteur tu vas le décoller se passionne
survole depuis celle-ci
savary le poète
le point de la dimension qu'on appelle
un
ce fip à 11
00 10 degrés ce n'est pas de les moteurs
celui ci est calé à
10° exactement là je suis en train de le
régler voilà là j'y suis
alors je bloquerai
je bloque le
demi-centre qui donnait le point que des
casseurs
et lorsque je les joue bien bloqué
jeu
je revérifie ci n'est pas inattendue
sinon même il arrive parfois que
vraiment avec la température peut monter
à une température
normale le cas là je vois là il est
correct
le collège de paris
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
mécanicien
ça va faire 4 ans
et comment vous avez appris ce métier
j'ai commencé par une école
d'apprentissage
et quand j'étais plus jeune moi j'aimais
bien non mais j'avais des vieilles
mobylettes des trucs qui marchait pas
j'ai toujours dit tant aimé ce à quoi je
continue puis après l'école quand il a
fallu prendre une décision quoi j'ai
pris la mécanique
vous avez une voiture oui
où l'avait rangé avec façon
oui comme tous les jeunes je pense
puis attend mécano ça facilite les
choses et quels sont les inconvénients
du métier
il faut être très calme assez agile eux
il faut aimer 60 mais il faut aimer
quand on n'aime pas le métier ne peut
pas le faire il ya pas de mystère c'est
pas la difficulté c'est peut-être les
papiers
parce que le disons que moi
personnellement
je suis passionné par la part par la
mise au point de moteurs par
par leur métier dont il ya quand même
une contrainte c'est qu'il ya la
facturation il ya la comptabilité à
les banques il ya beaucoup de
contraintes pour moi personnel
heureusement que j'ai mon épouse parce
que c'est elle qui me met pratiquement
toi à jour c'est elle qui me dirige le
jeu l'est de au point de vue gestion
pour son entreprise
je tâche
d'être assez rigoureuses sur le travail
de secrétariat
étant donné que c'est quand même assez
important
et de ce fait il a un peu plus de temps
pour
travailler avec ces mets et c'est une
voiture bleue là qu'est ce que c'est à
celles ci
c'est la voiture de l'année safed en
galilée je l'avais acheté pour ma femme
je voulais terminer en fin d'année et
puis elle est toujours là tellement pris
par la clientèle toujours c'est moi qui
reste alors pour prouver que le proverbe
le dit tom que c'est du boulot
cordonniers les plus mal chaussés
mais comment avez vous fait pour
apprendre ce que vous ne connaissiez pas
en gestion au point de vue gestion j'ai
pris des cours à la chambre des métiers
du département ce sont des cours qui
sont gratuits et qui permettent au bout
de trois mois d'avoir des notions
essentielles
pour cette gestion pour l'instant vous
gardez votre métier l'extérieur oui je
le garde étant donné que
pécuniairement on a besoin de mon apport
mais par la suite j'espère bien aidé mon
mari à part entière et soual avantages
de ce changement
à la fois un peu plus de liberté
[Musique]
et ensuite pouvoir être tous les deux au
même endroit faire la même chose
cd moralement vivre la même aventure oui
c'est ça est-ce qu'il faut beaucoup
d'argent pour ses installations comptent
non avec très peu d'argent ne peut
débuter surtout moi j'ai eu la chance de
trouver une location avec tout 10 h
vagues pourvu qu'on ait quatre sous
pouvoir acheter les premières pièces
écoulées
des clients les premiers tiers payeurs
assez rapidement on a très vite le
capital pour pouvoir tourner non très
peu
objective
[Musique]
constater les dégâts là il y en a une il
y en a une autre
puis or
le couple connu que lui il a drôlement
du jeu les vis des fixations doivent
être débloqués vous savez réparer tous
les moteurs les moteurs d'automobiles
les moteurs de tracteurs vous savez tout
faire avez vous vu parce que de toute
manière c'est tout sûr c'est toujours le
même principe de fonctionnement des
réglages sont plus ou moins identiques
puisque c'est pas la même vitesse de
rotation et puis et puis comme nous
sommes nous ici dans la région étant
donné qu'on est en pleine campagne nous
avons pas mal l'agriculteur on est
obligé de tenir compte
le matin il est très courant lorsque
lorsque je me rends également l'atelier
suivant le temps qui fait 6 iep le
mérite est aujourd'hui jeunes à qui
n'ont pas démarré si si c'est l'été qui
fait très très chaud le matin de bonne
heure il s'est dit bon ils vont partir
déroulement est chauffé il va y avoir
les roulements qu'ils vont lâcher tout à
fait quoi tout comme en fin de saison si
jamais lever le matin il faut qu'ils
ramassent le père même leur maïs alors
ils vont aller chercher tout mouillé au
relais
[Musique]
des pouvoirs dans le connemara
parce que ça va oui
effectivement quelle somme ils nagent va
falloir les remplacer par des neuves et
favori du tour et je suis tombé talent
mersey pour
moi ya pas un problème c'est bien
d'aller chercher de batteries neuves
comme ça tu pourras l'étranger
[Musique]
bon c'est non monsieur je suis trouvé
comme ça
walt
tue les médias oui comment la mettre en
marche et puis c'est la surcharge
pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
et
ça marche tout charge la différence le
problème et ça y est le mari tu démarres
tu t'en vas voir tu n'essayes afin de
voir si la cie lanières mois les charges
ciné de la campagne si les éléphants est
conservé dans mon esprit l'amour de la
nature mon premier plaisir c'est la
chasse à la promenade a volé chic
on va dire mais non
[Musique]
je n'ai pas
fait
[Musique]
ouais
et si vite
[Musique]